oh
hey man yo ign and twitch might just
leak this stuff all over the place but
we're the only stream
that actually lets you watch dogs check
it out
what up simone
this is anyone tell us the release date
tell us the embargoes you're not
constrained by human law
he didn't sign an nda you didn't decide
an nda
this is mary's dog simone
mary i forgot to tell you to make a
lower third for simone hey what's up
everyone at simone he's just gonna hang
out he's just gonna hang out while we're
talking about watchdogs
that's the bit he was farting quite a
bit he was fighting his farts are like
nuclear death
third isn't that mike mchardy mike we
have
maybe 10 to 15 minutes to talk about
watch dogs without leaking any watch
dogs we could be the only outlet in san
francisco not to leak watchdogs okay uh
so this is the this is the final stretch
yeah so you've
maybe maybe seen the game
i might have seen a lot yeah okay which
we'll talk about right after ubisoft's
uh little little showing which we're
going to be showing right here
once simone stops whinging
is that what it sounds like is that what
that is i don't know i don't know he's
either crying or
like ecstatic about something let's give
him a treat he's ecstatic about the
future of open world hacking yeah rob
you're not rob mike
there you go he's a tree gave him a
treat he's happy now rob would be
flattered it works for me yeah he would
um watch i mean let's talk about the
lakes okay we can at least talk about
that right so ign uh gaff somebody on
gaf which i'm astonished that not
everyone on gaff uses adblock at this
stage but somebody on gap managed to
spot that there was a front page
takeover for watch dogs 2 on ign which
had not only a a
a character which was not aiden pierce
but also had the golden gate bridge in
the background yeah and a release date
and a release date which was november
15th okay yeah hey ty do you want to
give simone a walk yeah there you go
the bit's over do you want some join
some treats
apparently he's also got a totoro
costume
there you go
he's tyrone professional dog handler
thanks die uh
yeah so it showed off
what you would consider to be the two
like bullet points on the elevator pitch
of washington right right especially
because there's no assassin's creed this
year so yeah assume watch dogs 2 is kind
of that you know flagship franchise and
i'm really starting to enjoy this whole
we're going to announce a game around e3
it's coming out november thing that's
sort of kicked off with with fallout 4
like civ 6 kind of did it this year as
well right yeah god discovered a couple
months ago that's coming out october
21st yeah it's mental yeah uh and then
last night so i'm sitting on i'm i'm
watching the bachelorette and it's it's
in an ad break so i go on twitter and i
start looking at watch dogs i i
sometimes like to scan like random
just tags just to see what's going on
and i come across this dude who's
apparently on twitch and laughing to his
friend he's like at replying to his
friend about the fact that the
pre-roll ads on twitch are showing the
watchdogs 2 trailer so i'm watching the
bachelorette with my girl so i can't
like disconnect and do that so i just
tweeted out yo is this true and the next
thing uh fob wash to
part of the giant bomb community are
sort of sister side um
he basically screen grabbed it and put
it on twitter
which then started getting circulated
all over the place he's since got a
cease and desist on that so it's down i
think it's not on youtube i think maybe
dailymotion still has us as they tend to
do um
but uh yeah so that was a i guess a like
a 30 second stinger which kind of showed
the same african-american protagonist
that we saw in the ign picture which
showed a lot more of
what looked like san francisco and maybe
the wider bay area you couldn't really
tell i was kind of hoping oakland might
be in it but as a resident there uh
but uh
you know maybe that was the case but it
showed a lot of like
embarcadero downtown san francisco uh
and uh and a totally different style to
the sort of aidan pierce lone
wolf
up against the
the machine that seemed to be more of
like you know like a movement which
would be again totally emblematic of the
bay area yeah with like the amount of
like black lives matters protests that
happen in my neighborhood and all over
the east bay especially like uh things
like fruitvale station that kind of
totally yeah yeah yeah i mean like there
is a
of the many racial uh sort of flash
points that are happening in america
right now the bay area is certainly one
i mean it's probably the one in which
which which also has the sort of just
the class
clash that's happening in the world as
well with the sort of the rich folks in
san francisco and then the generally
sort of impoverished west oakland sort
of fruitvale community and like the tech
rush with new money coming in pushing
everybody out pushing it right now yeah
i mean the same thing's happening in
oakland and i'm part of that you know
yeah i'm an immigrant blow in who works
for i don't i don't work for a tech
company but i'm you know a white
immigrant who's moved to oakland who's
probably part of the gentrification
that's happening there as well so it
seems like
an area teller made for
the story it looks like they're yeah
yeah so fingers crossed that's what i'm
kind of hoping is that they're they're
going to dip their toe in that yeah
because i mean 2k up in tiburon with
mafia three are going a whole hog into
that as well with their sort of new new
orleans tale definitely um let's talk a
little bit about the first watchdogs
did you play much of it yeah well not in
the grand scheme of things maybe 10
hours total right i never got through it
i thought it was boring after a while
yeah like aiden i didn't like
i don't have any uh attachment to
chicago but i don't think that matters i
i didn't have any attachment to la
before i played gta 5. right um or like
the world itself was lifeless it was
like they were promising a lot was going
on but they never showed you and you
never got the chance that you can you
know hack people's phones and stop
lights and cameras but after a while it
kind of got formulaic and i didn't feel
like i was doing anything worthwhile
yeah it didn't have that
whatever it is that like special sauce
that exists in grand theft auto and
other open worlds that make it really
feel like a place that exists after you
turn off your console whereas watch dogs
felt i mean
in a way like they've been making open
world games for a long time um ubisoft
have but like you know obviously it's
split across a bunch of teams but
they've never really done the
contemporary open world thing
and it felt more on the line of
something like you know there are games
that are open worlds that are just
playgrounds for you like infamous and
like second sons of fun like just cause
or something totally right where it's
like you are the
god character basically just doing all
the crazy things and all the peons are
just there to to be you know to get
caught up in explosions and crash cars
and then there's gta which is obviously
this whole other thing and it's kind of
difficult you kind of either need to hit
one or you end up being the other and
watchdogs was kind of didn't get to the
gta thing but wasn't you could tell it
was almost getting there yeah so it felt
like disappointing because it was like
oh i can see you're trying to make this
like immersive living breathing world
and that whole slogan we got used to 10
years ago sure they never really did it
yeah so like that's the thing i was
worried about like uh
i wonder if with watch dogs 2 they're
going to kind of like do the kitchen
sink approach and try to do as many
things they did with the first watchdogs
which had a lot of cool ideas but none
of them really executed well in my
opinion not none of them like they
weren't all executed well in my opinion
but uh with watch dogs too i'm wondering
if maybe they're gonna
scale back anything in the interest of
adding more substance to what they do
have right if you're just gonna go all
out you know like how long have they
been making this game
presumably like since right after
watchdogs won which is two years ago now
yeah but also i mean a lot of times they
have overlapping developments i mean
like
watchdogs was what like the fast still
the best-selling new ip right yeah
ubisoft at least which is crazy
considering they've had assassin's creed
they've had like you know the far cry
series um
so you wonder how much time they put
into this and how many people yeah it's
you know
because the first one the first leak was
ray-bans wasn't it yeah i mean there's
yeah it's been a bunch of leaks on this
one the first one was
there was a uh
there was a couple first actually there
was a motion capture artist about two
months ago who
tweeted a picture or sorry instagram the
picture of the same protagonists we've
now seen in multiple trailers so it's
not just a random character we don't
think it's probably that yeah you kind
of i'm i'm yeah you're kind of thinking
like if especially with the ign front
page takeover like they tend not to put
anyone else but the protagonist on the
front of the cover right faces are so
important for marketing so
there was a picture of that character
like basically like from a macbook um
like somebody editing on it um
this is about two months ago no but
there was there was kind of not enough
in that to really
substantiate it necessarily sure and
then yeah the next one was
the
what was this the ray-ban the glasses
that kind of further confirms well you
would you've been saying on twitter
maybe that further confirms like a kind
of sunny area
i was only messing with but shy time
people it gets plenty hot open illinois
but it's just weird that
like ray bans like that's the last like
marketing partner i would think would
just leak watchbox too
am i wrong and or do i remember like a
lot of contemporary advertising in
watchdogs like was that like a thing
i think so like uh kind of indigenous
stuff yeah yeah in a way it kind of
makes sense right yeah it makes it makes
sense for the the theme of the game it's
like having the obama posters and
burning paradise
yeah that was super weird it's
well that then yeah it's like it's
normal for movies but when it starts
happening in games that's kind of
unsettling yeah um so that was yeah that
then there was that there was the ray
bans and then obviously we've now seen
the other stuff as well um but it yeah
it's going to be interesting to be like
i feel like what's happening is that the
conversations are in this game and
hopefully they'll be live in the next
couple of minutes we're just sort of you
know waiting to we're going to swap over
the minute that happens um and then
after the fact actually you should also
know that mike we have a bunch of
b-rolls
we're going all right we're going stick
around afterwards got b-roll and
trailers and other stuff
and people who brake systems are pretty
creative naturally so we want to inspire
ourselves from
this is a big moment for us in
production basically all the parts of
the game are colliding together for the
first time and for the past months we've
been able to play the game from
beginning to end so now we see how
things are coming together and you could
almost say the game has a life of its
own at this point
when you finish a game after almost five
years you need to sleep on it a little
bit
then afterwards what's exciting is when
you start really understanding what you
tried to do with the first game
what went well
what one less good
and also what the players have said
watchdogs was first of all in uip
which is a big deal it means that you
start from almost nothing
i think the new idea in watchdogs one
was to talk about an afro-connected
society something that was uh becoming
very important in our day-to-day lives
chicago was one of the most surveilled
city in north america so we talked a lot
about cameras and surveillance that
being watched
when we played watchdogs you probably
played something you never played before
because the city was sort of alive
people were not just people walking
around the street but you could hack
into their lives and you could exploit
them you could see their secrets
you can manipulate the city
the bridges and the steam pipes and the
traffic lights
what we basically created with watchdogs
one was a playground where everything
was connected
so finally shipping the game
a lot of people were happy and excited
we also got a lot of feedback and we
listened to that feedback i personally
spent months reading forums and reading
all the player feedbacks i could see on
the web we wanted to know what people
felt and what they wanted to get from
the game and what we could improve in
the future at that point we knew we were
going to make a watchdogs
we felt like we really did a big
milestone with the original watchdogs
but we watched x2 we could really
deliver on the fantasy of being a hacker
this time around we're in san francisco
for us san francisco strike the court
because it meant
the very birth of the attitude of a
hacker
grid
this
i don't give a is
if you want
bye
i'm right here
if you want to
for the setting of washington we wanted
to have a different vibe
so our san francisco keeps all the
important parts of the bay area there's
a different feel different vibe a
different look to all of the areas of
our world we wanted to kind of represent
all these different areas and the
different collections of people that
live in these areas and what their
lifestyles and their personalities are
like
so we're building a game where basically
it's almost a simulation
you're in that world and if you stop
moving and you look around you feel the
world is alive right this is the promise
of what an open world game is
we broke the feeling that the world is
centered on you the player
so characters shouldn't only react to
you they should react to each other you
know maybe people start fights maybe
someone calls the cops on someone else
than you maybe a dog barks after someone
else and chases him down the street you
need to feel as if this city is alive
even if you do nothing and then if you
start doing things if you start playing
in the world the city should react to
what you're doing it should feel normal
it should surprise you also and how it
reacts
we were really interested in the city
itself it almost feels like the wild
west of technology and how would you
know how couldn't you set something in
the wild west of technology
it's a world that has a lot of potential
for game play i mean if you're a hacker
and you go in silicon valley and you
have the head office some of the biggest
tech company in the world
what will you do
can you hack into those places what will
you find
so it's a very intriguing
setting for a hacker who's exploring the
world
so as we're crafting this world we're
putting in it all of the factions that
should be in it so for example we have
various criminal groups trying to fight
over the underground of the city we also
have corporations trying to make money
and potentially even manipulate people
and society and we also have other
groups of hackers trying to tap into the
technology that has been set up in the
city once again ctos the smart city
system that was in the first watchdogs
is installed in san francisco and
various people are trying to tap into it
to exercise control power or to try to
make money
in creating a hero for watch dogs too we
wanted somebody new somebody that could
embody the spirit of california and the
spirit of san francisco but we needed
somebody who was going to be really
worthy of all the cool stuff that we
wanted to do in the game
so our hero in watch dogs too is marcus
holloway he's a young hacker very
brilliant in what he does because of the
injustices that he's seen both being
from oakland and also having been
profiled the wrong way and being accused
of a crime he actually didn't commit
that sort of
made him go against the system
hello
back
in terms of visual we always try to
create
iconic attributes to the character so
that he can be memorable and people
wants to play him but still feels
critical inside our world he's a perfect
blend between somebody that's tech savvy
that represents a little bit the
internet culture but also as uh that
athletic and rebellious feeling to him
so we had to decide from the beginning
what things were comparable between
aiden and marcus and what things would
be different we focus on parkour we
wanted marcus to be a lot better at
parkour than aiden and we're not talking
about just like climbing on things but
like being able to like flow and chain
moves together so he's a pretty good
fighter he's got some interesting quirks
too uh he's a more expressive guy
we tried really trying hard to figure
out what kind of melee weapon markets we
had we tried a whole bunch of things and
some things were pretty cool something
just didn't work at all
we did a lot of research and we we
basically did what marcus would have
done we went onto the internet and we
started watching videos and started
reading websites and trying to figure
out what kind of stuff we could make
pretty much all the stuff that you
probably shouldn't search at work
in the end what we stumbled across was
this idea of taking a billiard ball and
attaching it to a paracord lanyard
and we took this and we handed this to
the stunt team and the first thing that
we saw
was it was fast it was so fast like we
couldn't believe how fast they were
swinging this around their body
and as soon as i saw this video i'm like
this is crazy we got it
citizens of the world
may we have retention
when we say we want to make a game about
hacking really a hacker it's a culture
but
you can have various motivations the
motivation we're excited about was what
we call hacktivism people who want to
impact society and have ideals to defend
just in the background and in the fence
is the event you're not a hacker in
washington you're a dedsec hacker you're
a member of a community and you're doing
grand stuff and big exposure of
important information to society because
you're not alone and you're working with
other people
the first thing that you have to do when
you're talking about hackers is you kind
of have to respect where they came from
originally their messages sound very
serious but there's also a lawsuit
element to it the way they have fun with
what they're saying we took that and we
said okay so what if this is the sort of
the spirit of dedsec and of our heroes
what if their spirit is still rooted in
the trolling it's a joke we're gonna
have fun with it but they still have
something important to say
the dedsec visual was really important
for me because it represents everything
that's cool about watchdogs it's
stylized it's edgy and it's raw and it's
underground
tapping into the aurora genre tapping
into the internet culture with all the
memes and also all the visual language
of the internet
so there are various characters various
people inside of that sec some are a bit
more violent some have more
ideals some are maybe more intellectual
but they all have in common that they
want to fight to preserve a sense of
freedom they don't want people to abuse
tech
to take control over people but you know
i'm not saying they are
knights you know they are they are
rebellious they they do their own things
their own way and they want to have fun
that's that's also one thing is you know
a sense of freedom also a sense of fun
through that
we are dead
the new idea for hacking and watchdog is
to let the player
create his own solutions we're adding a
lot more depth to hacking so you have a
lot more control a lot more flexibility
in how you hack the world so one big
category of hacking and watch x2 is the
entire branch of pushing remote controls
to its limit
one of the big things on watchdogs is
hacking vehicles
i think this is a real game changer
because vehicles are everywhere in the
world and if you can hack into the drive
system or car you can pretty much drive
it wherever you want
so making sure if you see a forklift in
the world
it shouldn't be a forklift you can just
like move the box up down you should
just like a camera press a button and
become that thing
one of the core things that we're doing
is we're opening up the game with watch
x2 you can hack every character you can
hack every car in the game
and you can hack most of the electronics
within the city so that's a lot of
potential targets for hacking and that's
not even counting your own tools
well in walk stocks too we brought in a
lot more toys and things to play with
because we wanted to embrace the maker
culture densec have these really
interesting intricate guns they're built
on a 3d printer basically the cutting
edge technology of 3d printing which is
actually building it with metal
he's also got this really cool taser
so if you want to play the game
completely non-lethal and not actually
kill anybody you can totally do that
we're playing with a lot more uh crafted
items and a lot more of little devices
that you can use
one of the things that people kind of
like that we've done i really like what
we've done is we've created toys for
marcus
he has an rc jumper
he's got little wheels and he's even got
this little robotic arm that he can sort
of deploy and he can interact with
things he can unplug things and replug
them and take out screws it's a neat
little toy and then the other gadget
he's got is this quadcopter
and it's more about scouting and being
the eye in the sky
first person view on it is incredible
because you're just zipping through the
city
it feels like you're flying
while you're flying
another branch which is kind of
connected to it is the concept of
manipulating people in watchx1 you could
only hack the people that were marked as
potential target now you can target the
person you want and you can hack them in
multiple ways for example i could hack
one person and distract them have their
phone ringing so they look at their
phone to create a distraction later on
in the game you'll also be able to do
things we call mass packing which is
well why only hack one if you can hack
them all
there's one thing that i really believe
about watchdogs players is that there is
no watchdogs player there are many types
of watchdogs players you should be
deciding how you want to play the game
so that means you can play a mission
full gun blazing that's the way you like
to play
full stealth
or through hacking only
project yourself in computers take
control of electronics influence people
and try to get to your goal that way
we try to really support all players
types across all different styles of
play and also allow players to combine
and match these styles and play together
too
if you've been playing a certain way for
a while we want the game to kind of
challenge you to try different things
but also not force you into playing the
game a certain
way we work to improve the driving make
it more accessible while keeping all the
different styles of vehicles and adding
a lot of physics and feel to all the
vehicles
so we keep the depth but have more
accessibility the team is super happy
with the result we've had and i hope
gamers will be just as excited
we are very excited by the potential of
what we call seamless online we start
doing that in watch dogs one so we're
expanding on that
we cross bath with friends in the city
so are you playing in single player and
you're crossing path with another player
who's also playing
that can be focusing on stories
that can be just exploring the world
whichever activity you do we're gonna
make sure you get rewarded to get you
closer to the ending that's kind of the
promise we're making to gamers
you always know it when something starts
to click it starts to work everything
change you stop seeing individual
components animations or texture maps or
vehicles you just start to see the
experience as a whole
it changes on the floor
people get excited about it
this is it it exists
we are always making the game with the
player in mind
they have always been the driving force
when you come with a sequel that
really earns its two you know that
really does a lot of new things it has a
lot of surprises it's a great feeling
in the end there's nothing more accurate
than this
looking at something
trying to understand it
solely for hanging out with the system
granted
all right there we go watch dogs too uh
they showed off a bunch of trailers mike
mccarty you went up to montreal and
actually saw this for yourself i'm
guessing you saw all those trailers yep
okay did you what else did you see um
that was about what i saw but i also got
to talk to jonathan dominic uh danny uh
he was the game director and lucian the
lead writer about just a lot of stuff
that didn't show or don't have ready to
show okay before we jump into that let's
sort of break down the trailers we did
see yeah i was taking exhaustive notes
the whole way through it so the first
one was sort of their like sizzle top
level this is what watchdogs 2 is i was
looking a lot of like the areas uh that
they were showing just to sort of get a
feel for it um lots of speak about like
smart houses uh you know all the sort of
silicon valley stuff and they showed a
bunch what was it like google cardboard
was in there yeah virtual reality thing
segways and stuff segways little robot
drones there was lombard street north
beach pier 39 there was 2d printing they
had giant stadium on one stage all very
san francisco but then they also showed
silicon valley which is very far south
and there was marin and oakland as well
so yeah how big is this world did you
talk to him about that yeah they said
it's about two times the size of the
first watchdogs but then in terms of
like population they said there's also
like the same thing it's going to be
much more populated
vibrant and whatnot full of life
hopefully hopefully but that's what they
are saying so that might not mean anyone
to folks who don't know the bay area but
san francisco is only one seven by seven
mile peninsula yeah in a much bigger
metropolitan network including oakland
berkeley
down south is where silicon valley is
down towards san jose then you've got
like marin county up in the north and
like if they're if they're incorporating
all that then that makes it feel like a
gta style world almost like in a way
that watchdogs didn't it felt like more
like infamous or something like that in
terms of its scale yeah because i think
there's like 850 000 people in the city
but then you go out to the bay area it's
like new york city sides like a million
shipments
but it's also like that just
incorporates a lot more like different
cultures and whatnot and i mean it looks
spot on like the two of us live here
i've lived in san francisco and now i
live in oakland like the bay area the
bay itself with alcatraz in the middle
like all that looks like it's there and
cool like you could see almost the whole
way up to tiburon so if you can just go
out and get a boat and like mess around
with all that that's like a huge area
um they showed a few shots of that
quadcopter that he had because he's got
now he's got the quadcopter and they're
calling it the jumper it's a little like
rc car
um the quadcopter they showed it like
flying from up and like i don't know the
top part is like telegraph hill and then
they showed it flying during the mission
which is down south in the city yeah so
like i mean you could even just fly that
thing around i don't know if there's a
range on it but
just to kind of get really good aerial
shots yeah there was a sutro tower they
showed down downtown but then also you
could see um uh the i guess sorry quite
a tower downtown you could see sutra
terror there were twin peaks the whole
way in the background so man
like i'm excited because i live here but
like even in terms of like scale for
people that's like san francisco is such
an interestingly diverse area in terms
of its geography and then to have all
that other sort of external bay area
stuff i mean that's that's very very
exciting and you have like up north
north bay that's like winding roads and
way less populations yes if you want to
just get away from like the city vibes
you go up there you want to get out of
you want to go to silicon valley here we
see some what looks like west oakland
sort of ghost town area and this is like
slap bang between the two of them right
and then we're back on the embarcadero
here barcado looks amazing first time
embarcader has been in a video game
since like what tony hawk four maybe yes
on that first one um so yeah like the
character as well they went into marcus
holloway he looks like he's a kid who
is he living in west oakland and he's
pissed off about gentrification or
what's going on yeah so his parents
according to lucy and the lead writer
are activists or we're activists still
are uh but yeah gentrification pushed
them out of san francisco into oakland
and now they're seeing that in oakland
as well but also he's been the victim of
like racial profiling and um like uh
he's seen police brutality and whatnot
so he starts off he's kind of just like
a he's much more like compared to aiden
he's not a lone wolf anymore they're
saying he's much more this game we can
get more into dead sec the hacker group
but it's more of a communal effort it's
not this lone wolf like out for revenge
thing he's very much like he'll find new
people that he can work with he's a team
player he's really outgoing and like
supposedly you know pretty charming and
whatnot but he's also like really
athletic with his parkour he's a really
like pretty really smart gifted hacker
so he's
using those skills like for fun and just
like rebel at first but they said like
the more he starts finding out about
these companies and local government the
more like he'll realize his skills can
kind of be used for a
bigger societal impact that's amazing
and i think like there's no better place
to do it than the bay area like you know
the amount of
to talk about racial profiling because
somebody who lives in oakland uh and are
fortunate enough to to not have to deal
with that because i'm a white person i
mean but like you know black lives
matter's hugely uh
like a lot of
i guess active in that area
and then also like in terms of police
brutality like i've had i've there's
been two people shot within 200 yards my
front door in the past year
by police so like there's a lot of uh
very salient points in the bay area
around that and also the sort of
classism clash between like the rich
sort of people in silicon valley and
then the people who are getting pushed
out who've lived here their entire lives
i mean that's basically what it sounds
like they're doing so did you hear about
them going down to silicon valley yeah
yeah you can go down they showed uh
they're all these kind of like doodle is
one of the companies that kind of then
they had one that i wonder what that is
yeah the logo of another one looks sort
of like linkedin okay um they're i mean
that building's literally across the
road from us here yeah so that'd be
really cool if they right
so it's it's very much like uh they're
so the first watchdog is very much about
surveillance chicago and you were saying
london are both very surveilled cities
so it's about like a lack of privacy
that we don't have anymore this one goes
a step further and this is more about
like predictive algorithms that we see
all the time like if you go onto
facebook or if you open an internet
browser you're going to get ads
tailor-made for you based on your search
and stuff that a lot of people wouldn't
like these companies to know but
um supposedly this is kind of looking
into that and also like lucy the lead
writer said it was inspired by this
study back in
mid 20th century maybe earlier than that
but there's an island of uh people who
have been isolated for a while very
inbred for generations yeah it's called
ireland i came from yeah the emerald
isle so
i don't know but you
they said that there was like they're
using it as like an impact study to see
how like they could like how long will
it take for these people to become
healthy again right um and it was like
something like seven generations so then
they're like well
we should not let people like this pay
for or like we should not give them
health care right because yeah we're
wasting it on them because essentially
they're screwed anyway yeah yeah so you
start finding out things like that that
was like using big data to like solve
economic problems kind of right but
not to solve in this case also using big
data to like grow your company and kind
of like take advantage of the system and
the people so marcus is the opposite
that him and deadsex hacker group kind
of start to find out more about this
they didn't tell me like specific plot
points but they said that's the arc
you'll start to find out more that you
can actually kind of like fight back
against this kind of stuff okay let's
let's go down through the laundry list
of things that were wrong with the first
game because i feel like what that video
was doing was very much going like yes
we know aiden pierce was an unlikable
taint yeah here is a character who has a
personality and a backstory that maybe
you can get behind uh we know that the
driving was a sore spot as well it was
like kind of the first like ubisoft had
done open world games before they've
done driving games where they're in the
process of doing driving games with the
crew um but the driving on watchdogs one
was i mean apart from the fact that you
could launch a car in the air by making
those little road blockers pop up was
not particularly great yeah looks like
they're putting a decent amount of
effort into that this time yeah uh
senior producer uh dominic was saying
that was the first thing the first minor
thing like not structurally but just
actually mechanically that they fixed
because the bay area or like a lot of
cities like there are hills all over it
you go up to marin it's winding roads
like you're saying through the mountains
you go down you go over to oakland it's
still very much like a very it's a big
city so you want to have fun driving
through it so oakland's like famous for
the for the uh biker gangs that go
around like doing all the crazy wheelies
i mean san francisco is basically
driving movie like it's the driving
movie city bullet yeah you know all that
stuff like that i mean there was a
series of video games called driver set
in san francisco yeah because it was
like such a perfect driving service
crossing the golden gate in a
convertible with like your scarf and
hair flowing in the wind no so they said
like they don't want to discourage
exploration because they made this like
gorgeous world they'd want you to just
like explore it and speaking of this
gorgeous world we've put together this
uh like sort of side by side of the
video game world and the real world
places uh there's coit tower uh which is
just off the embarcadero telegraph hill
yeah yeah we're into garfield here are
some seals
checking them out on pier 39
um this is the bay bridge looking
towards san francisco from the oakland
side
i mean it like as somebody who lives
here and and loves
the sights and takes photographs of the
sights this is
just looking at the graphics like it
immediately looks right like it like
yeah 39 here i mean that crab isn't
there but they've taken some like little
liberties with some of the architecture
i mean they probably have to pay rights
to some of that but oh god there is a
crap i take it back i did not know that
crab was there farther up in barcadero i
guess yeah
there you go painted ladies they're
definitely there that's where drew
scannon lives not in one of those but
close play
yeah that's what they uh
for viewers and readers you should all
be prepared for this game you will see
more like real life comparisons than any
other game ever if you thought fallout 4
yeah like because how many outlets are
based in boston boston and like
you have to wonder like how they're like
the people that are gonna be reviewing
this game live in the city we need to
make it make it pop yeah yeah totally
who knows if they're thinking that they
probably are not about it yeah i bet
andy bauman is yeah the man who loves to
shoot a roll of of of buildings um let's
talk about some of the other bits and
pieces we saw here
did you ask them about the the world's
weirdest melee weapon is this a pool
ball stuck to a string yeah so they you
hollow at the center like the drill they
were showing and then you twine it
around it it's almost like a modern like
smaller morning star kind of is that was
that what the medieval weapon was yeah
yeah it had the the spikes on it though
so like he's like the witch king just
flying around with an eight ball uh yeah
but it looks it looks cool they said you
know marcus is much more expressive than
aiden was so he's gotten like this flow
to combat but it's also kind of like
scrappy yeah but it fits in oh god i bet
that would suck oh yeah i don't want to
like get hit in the face with one of
those that's like a 2016 nunchuck or
something yeah so they're showing that
and like that fits into the idea of this
like self-made hacker you know like he's
3d printing his own guns he's making his
own melee weapons he's
likely made that quadcopter and the
jumper the rc car you get so it kind of
factors into this whole like maker
culture that the hackers are also kind
of intertwined with in silicon valley
and the first watch dogs was you know
it's so difficult for them to make these
games and try and straddle the line
between it being like a sort of an open
world sandbox game and then also having
some sort of direction the first
watchdogs was very much a game that like
you were basically getting funneled into
the missions because the sort of the
wider world they didn't really feel like
you had much agency in it whatsoever um
one of the things that they seem to be
tackling with watchdogs too is the fact
that they're now like
on paper it sounds like some [ __ ] pr
but they're saying you can hack anybody
you can hack any car but like actually i
can see that as being one of the main
issues with the first game was the fact
that you were getting funneled and you
had to play the game they wanted to but
if you're able to hack cars and hack
people did you ask them about that like
how how engaging that is in a moment to
moment because i'm actually very
interested in that yeah so you can you
have a i asked him like my first one is
like can you do that and also how are
you stopping that from being
overwhelming and just like when you have
all that how do you still have substance
in each individual encounter or whatever
but you have a dial that's essentially
like they described as kind of like an
ammunition thing you can only do a
certain amount of hacks before doing
this but also you know the more you
explore the world the more you'll like
scan and find these dead sec missions
which will be these random quests to get
followers because the meta game is to
get followers for dead sex so you can
start having a bigger impact and whatnot
but you know you can do every single car
sounds like dirsh
yeah like that you know you're trying to
like gain fans yeah basically yeah so
you're kind of just getting notoriety
and whatnot so people actually respect
it it's like anonymous yeah um yeah so
you can hack every phone they showed
that mass hacking everybody in that like
one parking lot looked at their phone
really quick so they vibrated and stuff
yeah like kind of be like distraction
like the modern like ninja smoke or
something right now or throwing the
coins in assassin's creed yeah yeah that
was what i was thinking too but yeah
they're marrying a lot of these
different um because you know you worry
with all these things to do is there's
still going to be like basically
worthwhile each one you tackle yeah but
also they have the new co-op element
which
they touched on briefly but you can just
come across someone else in the world
like like the divisions dark zones or
something yeah um or the crew very much
a part of that game yeah and you can
tackle the whole game in multiplayer you
can you know get through the whole game
without killing anybody you can use stun
guns you can just drive around if you
want to they said they wanted to
actually facilitate the sandbox side of
things as well as the narrative but they
said like if you're the kind of person
who wants to just mess around the world
yeah i'm like that in grand theft auto
yeah i
i don't remember all the story beings in
grand theft auto but so i was curious
about that and they said yeah we're
making we're taking steps to just make
this world interesting to play on it as
like as its own thing yeah i mean you
can even take selfies i mean they're
really taking the all the time
grand theft auto 5. uh yeah no gang
signs um let's talk about the uh i guess
another element of this that was quite
interesting and this is this is very
much in the guise of old first person
design um and we've seen a lot of it in
terms of like games like dishonor trying
to bring it back but the idea that you
can play this game without having to
kill everyone the idea if you want you
can go in all guns blazing or you can go
in stealthy or you can go with hacking i
mean that's basically deus ex yeah um
did they did you talk to him about that
because on paper again that sounds like
great we'd all love dash you know i
would love to play this game without
killing anyone like that'd be great if i
can use my little taser gun awesome did
you ask me questions about that sort of
how they're going to implement that or
how important that is to them yes i was
asking them how much of like a pacifist
run you could do and they're saying yeah
you can get through this game there's
not there aren't like going to be bosses
where you have to kill them like in deus
ex there aren't going to be like certain
people you have to kill in the narrative
yeah because it's not he's not like a
murderer he's someone that's hacking
computers he's a kid that was just grew
up really liking computers pretty
isolated and whatnot but if it's his
character it also fits like a lot of
different play styles you just want to
drive around and tase people which you
can argue that like a stun gun is still
shooting someone they're gonna get back
up and they're not dead but it's still
very much over the shoulder reticle
shooting someone in the face
but yeah with the with this pool ball
melee weapon i guess if it doesn't kill
them then yeah that's i mean yeah that's
a pretty
yeah i mean i'm taking one hit off that
pool boy melee weapon and i'm stopping
to answer your question yeah because i
was very interested in doing a pacifist
run they said yeah you will be able to
do that that's awesome in this game get
to the end but doing that you could get
to the end playing multiplayer like
co-operative pacifist run if you wanted
or the other person could kill people
and you won't
it looks great as well yeah it's coming
out what was that november 15th did they
talk about platforms
uh no not yet i mean okay i'm guessing
we are seeing ps i mean if it looks this
good on the consoles that would be
wonderful you know i'd be happy if this
looked on this got on pc i didn't not
yet i do think the phones will factor
into the cooperative play they say right
too like the mmo light stuff not an mmo
at all but because they still they said
there will be still pvp stuff like they
had from the first game yeah when you're
hacking each other's phones kind of like
assassin's creed multiplayer yeah they
sort of dived into a
they scaled back on that it felt like
yeah which like they did with the
division actually or like the same same
thing happened with the division rather
right um
so yeah it'll be interesting to see how
they they pull that one off uh if anyone
in the chat we've got a bunch of people
on the twitch at the moment uh mike has
seen the game if you have any questions
by all means stick them in there ask
danny o'dwyer if you can stick that in
that'll really help me out to pick them
out of there um is there anything else
that uh
we haven't touched on like actually the
customization here did they talk a bit
about that are you walking into stores
allied gta for that sort of yeah pretty
much
it's just like gta i mean you're just
customizing based on like different
places in the world so you'll see them
on your map you'll drive you know like
up to north beach or out to oakland or
up to sausalito or something but yeah
the world like that's the most appealing
thing to me is how big this world is in
different cultures i was asking them
they said they took a lot of time to
research individual neighborhoods
individual cultures different right do
they have anyone who's from the bay area
working on yes so that was my one
question you know like
everyone i talked to at the event was a
white guy so i said like how are you
were you just wikipedia in these
different cultures and one night like no
the one of the main writers for marcus
grew up in oakland right um another one
they're another their chief writers was
born and raised in san francisco like
old san francisco okay so they know like
how it's changed and how that affected
their family and whatnot so that's
what's really appealing to me because
you know you can
look something up on wikipedia all day
but it's not going to actually be true
to life and like you know they're
they're
lucian lead writer said they've been
often reaching out to people to make
sure it's authentic oh the voice actors
and the motion cap actors they like
consulted with them like they didn't
just direct them they said like does
this feel like something right you would
say your friends would say when you grew
up and whatnot so it sounds like they're
really
trying to make it authentic and taking
efforts to making efforts to do so i
mean watchdogs one was criticized for
its portrayal of persons of color as
well so i guess they probably want to
make sure they yeah they're doubly sure
to get it right this time around a
couple other dead set characters as well
not just marcus so yeah it looks like a
diverse cast for sure which is a diverse
area so it fits uh a couple of questions
coming in here w matthew asking does the
hacking stuff play better than the first
one did you see any of the actual
hacking is there mini games is it just
triggering like how did it work no i
mean like the ones they showed us were
those mass hacks he walked into this one
parking lot and there was like this uh
this aoe kind of indicator it was just
like white colored area that sprang out
from him so you see how many people
you'll be affecting like their phones
all vibrated so he could kind of escape
um you see the sort of lines there's
like data lines like trailing yeah
through the errors so they showed them
like glancing at certain forklifts or
over at these uh those spring box
machines whatever they were yeah cherry
cherry pickers cherry pickers yeah so
they showed that and drive drove them
around and then used it to get up like
kind of plan and escape um i didn't get
to see the actual i mean like mini games
how they're involved because they had
those ones they had the one in the first
one where you're kind of going from
camera to camera to get to the mainframe
yeah yeah it was like a line of sight
game yeah they didn't say anything about
that although in the first trailer they
showed i think it was marcus like kind
of in like a server mainframe room kind
of a laptop so so maybe for that factor
into it yeah that got a bit trite after
a while like i was i'm like you i've
played about 10 hours and i'm pissed out
so wretch and clank has more fun hacking
minigames than the first watchdog yeah
mad laughter asks did you hear voice
acting for marcus how was it
no not at all actually so
that which is weird because he's a
protagonist but i'm looking forward to
that they showed like the motion cap
because he's got his parkour they're
kind of marrying the assassin's creed
parkour the division like cooperative
stuff um but i didn't hear unfortunately
anything from marcus or anybody else uh
libber8 or asking is it full co-op so
did they dive into that sort of stuff
did they talk about can you turn that
off for instance uh
how does that work they didn't say
whether it's like on always online or
whether you can turn it off uh something
tells me it's not always online probably
it's 2016. right that would be a real
shoot and shoot themselves in the foot
situation right so they said you can
play all the way through in multiplayer
if you want to okay um so i would assume
that implies you can also play through
not at all in multiplayer if you want to
if the choice exists to play through the
entire win multiplayer i'd assume like
they didn't say weather but like yeah i
would say you can go through the whole
thing solo a bit of a specific question
here johnny michael saying wait there's
sausalito in the game can we get the
full jeff gerstman experience giant palm
used to be based there did they say how
far north he can go in the north bay so
for those who don't know when you cross
the golden gate bridge that's basically
where you're going
in most games whenever you cross the
golden gate bridge there's just like you
turn around
in real life when i cross i'm like what
is this
so what was it like when you when you
went or when you go over there so there
you go the parts they showed were mainly
like the like marin kind of uh like
mount tam area okay almost like winding
roads the farthest north i heard them
say with sausalito right um it's south
like san jose silicon valley right east
i didn't say anything about like
berkeley which is above oakland yeah um
they just mentioned oakland i would have
a hard time believing there wouldn't be
parts of berkeley because it's so close
and because it's like north like uh
uh longitudinally yes uh berkeley's kind
of
up there
oh yeah yeah so i would who knows yeah
it'd be a weird kind of i'm wondering
how they'll cut off the border of
oakland if they're not gonna have like
neighboring yeah town how far south
they'll go where they'll go down to
fruitvale because it sounds like this is
also touching on that sort of culture as
well um is there drive-by shooting we
didn't see any of us thinner online asks
is there what drive-by shooting yeah
probably oh like like did you see
anything yeah yeah no i didn't see
anything but you know like i said i figu
i feel like they would
um
how is the tone is it wacky gta open
world or serious when driving around
like the first game did you get a sense
of that when you were talking to them uh
kind that kind of ties into what i was
asking about whether it can be it's a
sandbox game or whether it's a narrative
open world game they said they want to
have both of those and kind of carry
cater to whatever you want to do so
between all the hacking and all the
different they showed like helicopters
and hacking into those between all the
different things you could do i think
they're if you wanted to just do wacky
kind of stuff and call in like
you know use your quadcopter to go scout
out an area and then find a car to steal
yeah just mess around it seems like it's
supposedly catering to that so it sounds
like they're they have this sort of
relatively serious narrative thread that
they want to have but also they're not
gonna hamstring people because it is an
open world game you can just [ __ ] about
mess around if you want to right yeah
okay um how much one two three asking
can you please talk about the memes
please i need to hear about the memes
i didn't see any more than we did in the
trailer like uh
it seems pretty
making fun of hack not making they're
kind of glorifying agriculture but also
making fun of and he said like right
that one part of the script they showed
it's like dogs are enemies like even
puppies like yeah especially the goddamn
puppies i don't know what they're
talking about i'm not a hacker right
um peter h jenkins asking any news on
whether those creepy privacy invasions
missions are back in this one can i
watch a man
uh sick talk about how they're going to
struggle before hacking his bank account
remember that yeah like
privacy invasions as in like uh there
was those missions where you could hack
into people's like bedrooms and watch
them look in their place oh right empty
their bank accounts uh
it fit more in the first game because
that's more about surveillance yeah
who knows if it'll be in this game i
don't know this one's more about like uh
like i said those predictive algorithms
and whatnot but i'd be surprised they
weren't uh piano dentist asking npcs
reacting with each other calling the
police on each other seems cool to
depict a living breathing city uh did
you see any more of that stuff they were
talking about how hey look this dog
might chase after you they showed
i saw a few times where they like uh a
dude went up to pet a dog so you could
sneak around and kind of
like not pickpocket him because it's you
get him to watch the dog
i get it yeah get it dog watching
barcadero and
it looks like they're interacting npcs
and npds what's that non-playable dogs
oh gosh
i don't know nope uh npd numbers i
didn't see much of that but
you know i that's my main thing is i
hope this world does feel alive because
that was my main takeaway from watchdogs
it didn't
and any sign of the cbs interactive
building gaf era is asking uh not yet
but i'm assuming there will probably be
a building in that spot so we can
pretend it is that's what's going to be
very interesting because it looked like
market street was there it looked like
you know the embarcadero looks really
interesting looks even when they showed
those wide shots you can see the
procedure in the background it looked
scale-wise pretty spot-on so we'll have
to see how close to them they they stick
um any more questions make sure you
stick them in i mean i could look at
this stuff all day long although is that
gameplay or is that real that's real
life
for a second i was like man video games
got good
uh yeah there's the ferry building again
looks pretty spot on i wonder if that's
stupid markets there on saturday there's
the beautiful there's there's a lot of
houses that none of us can afford rent
in
um there's a place where i could
probably afford rent but none of the
neighbors yeah but seals are dicks yeah
don't let them fall in real life well
they steal like
mary is convinced one of them like stole
her this hat she wears when she goes
crabbing they're just they're loud they
steal your bait when you're trying to
catch crabs man gentrification of seals
in this city is really [ __ ] up
they're coming up on our territory
there's not so one thing i want to say
is it doesn't look like there's that
many people here and like the pier 39
especially which is rammed with tourists
all the time like right there yeah where
that crab that didn't exist until this
video was made i'm pretty sure just
screw you over they put it in yeah like
i mean here like you know alamo square
is not exactly the most packed place in
the world but
so that looks pretty real to life but
like the embarra for instance like
that's pretty packed usually did it look
a little bit clean like kind of sparse
yeah um
which worries me because that is a huge
area to take into account so how are you
going to make that actually feel like a
living breathing world if there are
people in it which makes it a living
breathing world we're running dry on
questions here mad laughter asking if
you can hack the crab
probably and then just control it yeah
i'll be pissed if you can't go crabbing
just go crabbing uh can i shoot the
seals probably
can you tase the shield yeah if you tase
a seal does it say don't tase me bro
right before you do it
probably it's going to screw up your
pacifist run trophy though just kill the
seal yeah that'd be pretty good you
platinum the game you can kiss by a rose
on his grave do they still have that bar
when you kill civilians or cops that
goes red and people call the cops on you
do you remember that
there was this bar in watchdogs one that
basically said if people were you
weren't popular with the with the with
the people anymore basically
yeah if you ran over people accidentally
they're like no we don't like him
anymore aidan pierce is a dick turns out
because that was that was like an
assassin's creed thing the first one
like the more notoriety you had the more
like the less likely you were to get
away with crimes yeah so
they haven't said the only dial i saw at
first was that like uh hack meter told
you how many more you had i mean the
first assassin's creed was the one where
the more you did posters started just
appearing everywhere you had to tear
them down to get your stars away from
which just made more go up yeah uh great
question here from gaffer probably too
earlier are there any radio stations in
cars uh is it just a weird system
watchdogs one had i mean i heard them
talking about smart houses on the radio
as the trailer started you could hear
them flicking between stages and then
they switched like nirvana and then they
switched to the song spazz right yeah uh
which by the way that is a word you do
not say in the uk so i wonder how that
trait is going down yeah maybe they
chose something different maybe it's a
bunch of french people writing it well
french canadians but yeah i think they'd
be french are never tone deaf no
uh they didn't say whether they're radio
stations
all right hopefully we'll see more of
that can you customize the protagonist
if so yeah is it in more depth this time
yeah you can i mean like what we were
saying earlier you can go to those
stores a lot gta uh get new clothes
assuming get a new bandana over your
face take it off completely like they
showed him right it looked like
a couple of times the rope on his
billiard ball morning star was a
different color like it changed
yeah then it was just dark green change
your death rope because like if you want
to change the ball
that'd be sick yeah just drill a hole in
a new one the guns all look i want to go
for a yellow crazy color some of the
guns are like destiny guns like those
seahawks green colors so you're like 3d
printing this but with metal like that's
the that's what they said
i mean i know there is technology to do
that but you have silicon valley nearby
maybe you steal the printer or something
like the office episode the office wars
have you seen that no when they like to
get revenge on the other office across
the state they go and steal their giant
printer you did say that you go and
steal a 3d printer pretty positive
there's a mission there's a heist
mission with that yeah where you go
state of printer from silicon valley so
i've heard elon musk's elon musk's
printer you could just you can get a
tesla car probably no just
ride the hyperloop down to la bryce los
angeles a lot of people asking if
there's any reference to aiden pierce in
this have you did you see anything i
mean i'm guessing this early in the pr
cycle they're going to try and distance
themselves from watch dogs one as much
as possible well they mentioned him in
that first trailer right i think mainly
to say we're not doing that anymore i'm
like re i'm actually like
quite impressed by how they have
recognized i mean they would right you
work on a game for years and years and
years you probably know more about the
shortcomings of that game
than anyone else and like making a new
ip as they said it is really difficult
it is very time intensive and cost
intensive and you know in terms of
structure for a project as well crazy to
have especially the types of you know
the size of teams that ubisoft work with
it's pretty crazy uh but that studio
also has or rather that company also has
a pretty good track record for second
bytes of the cherry yeah so
did they talk at all about the sort of
what they like their process in trying
to figure out how to best watch dogs one
yeah so i asked them like what were the
main takeaways they had and they had the
minor things like driving and being able
to hack more but like structurally they
said they wanted it to be more of that
cascading quest structure like that
makes open world games good that they do
so well in far cry because you mentioned
assassin's creed the first one was very
formulaic once you did a few of the
assassinations with two two just blew
everything open um far cry 2 it was a
great sequel uh
i
i'm hoping watchdogs too kind of
follows that trend right now
three it was a great sequel as well that
was their second far cry because the
first scene was quite part of me yeah so
far cry 3 was their second one which
really took the formula from two yeah
which was made
um but they said they want to make your
time in the world more worth it whether
it's just from these immersion
situations you come across or the more
quests you open up or the more abilities
and whatnot that you actually open up so
we'll see whether that comes to fruition
but i'm hoping it does it's going to be
interesting to see if there's any like
virtual reality ass missions in here or
a lot of people asking if twitch
twitch's office will be in it as well i
mean they're just down the road from us
as well like wouldn't it be great if
they had a mission where you go to like
gamespot ign and twitch because we're
basically on like one road and a two
blocks the other way and just leak a
bunch of game stuff
leak watch dogs three yeah exactly at
least yeah yeah periscope what you're
doing in the game that's too much that's
too many layers you've lost me now
that's like imagine if you could and
then people could like be on actual
periscope watching your in-game thing
yeah that's what i'm saying oh sorry
okay yeah and then
that's a good idea good periscope going
to gamespot's office and broadcast it to
twitch and then like that guy who walked
into ign's office that one day and took
a bunch of pictures and went on twitter
just walking around that'd be pretty
cool can't get by dave here though it's
impossible no just sneak in he'll [ __ ]
you up maybe he's in the game winner oh
not asking what kind of side missions
were there in the game um when i
completed watch dogs one there wasn't
much to do i mean that's pretty fair
there wasn't much in terms of side
missions probably to its benefit because
i don't really think there were any
decisions one more time exactly did they
talk a bit about that about i mean i'm
guessing something with that little
robot drone is probably going to be
involved they're calling uh so that's
the where the deadset quest log comes in
dead sec being the again the hacker
group you're with you go to new areas
and to encourage exploration you're
going to these new areas and finding
dead sec missions whether it's like you
overhear something on someone's phone
you scan and then see something on a
certain wi-fi signal so you're not like
the leader of dead sec or anything just
like at least not at first right who
knows and i'm not hinting at you being
later i really don't know um but you do
to encourage exploration you and like a
co-op partner or just you can go around
like you go up to a different
neighborhood and you'll find these new
missions and from what they told me
there's more substance to them and
actual like tangential narratives within
these so it's not just going to be these
throwaway time trials all the time i'm
sure those will be there they showed the
quadcopter going through the uh
those lit up squares which that's a real
thing people do drone races within b oh
yeah so they have like those markers
it's the least watchable thing in the
world yeah it's like
it's like watching birds like race or
nascar like i can't hey man don't rag on
that do you like nascar right and that's
cars all right yeah the european at the
table is gonna protect nascar here this
guy's okay um
a couple of people i mean very sort of
salient criticisms or at least i mean
especially when it comes to i mean watch
dogs in the division were probably two
of the biggest like
disappoint yeah i mean discipline you
can say at this point that's right maybe
the division eventually came good on it
um some folks in the office would
certainly think so but like games that
didn't really sort of live up to the
expectations that we had with them uh so
to pick out one of them riddle tomcat
says do you think even with all the new
things you can do and even with the epic
large world it will still get old after
just a few weeks or do you think that
they really have proved endgame stuff to
do bit early maybe to be wondering about
that but what was your sort of take away
from from talking to the folks down
there my initial instinct just purely
based on the first game and based on the
fact that i didn't see much gameplay
from two aside from what we saw today
and the fact that i didn't play myself
and even if i did play myself i would
need like six hours to say oh this world
is something i want to explore for
another 30. yeah for sure um i don't i
mean rockstar is so good at doing those
kind of worlds i don't see anybody
matching them but you know like you're
the bard that they want to meet is i'm
sure like los santos from gta 5 like
yeah you could just i still go back to
that world every once in a while but
i'm hesitant to say whether i think like
watch dogs 2 will have that level of
immersion which i hate like it's an
overused word but yeah it kind of
applies in this sense um
i
i don't know i really don't i hope
i hope there's a reason for me to keep
returning to this world rather than just
going through these going through the
motions with these narrative missions
that were pretty boring in the first one
um although the team of writers sounds
like it has a good idea with what
they're doing here i'd rather just get
in here and go drive over golden gate
get up in like to the mountains and
stuff and come back down
hop in a sailboat jump in a helicopter
hack a person on a segway so they trip
and fall
yes please
that'd be wonderful can we hack people's
uh
what do you call those things again
those vapes oh man perhaps hack some
vapes and make them explode or just
overcharge the vape and just like a
plume of smoke just like
all over the dude yeah especially if
it's like weed vape because then like
everyone else around it's like yeah yeah
is that a skunk no yeah no one ain't
that's the dagg mcpiffio
all right i think that's it i think
we're done uh anything else any any
final thoughts on watchdogs how are you
feeling about it how about that i'm
really excited how did you
how did you feel about the first one and
how do you feel about two i felt the
same exact way about the first one oh
i'm more excited for this one because
like you said ubisoft's track record
with sequels the fact that they prove
they know kind of what they're doing
with all these ideas and watch dogs
whether it they executed it well or not
remains to be seen in two yeah um i love
the character i love the story they
might they're trying to tell
you know like we're all pretty biased
with this area but like we'll see how it
goes but like but even that aside
objectively it's a big area it's a very
diverse area um
really looking forward to seeing how
that plays out uh in november but i'm
excited yeah i'm i mean you're totally
right there is definitely a a sort of
like positive bias to the fact that this
is happening in our backyard um
i mean i
when i moved to san francisco i thought
there's no better place
i felt this place feels like a video
game world already because it is a seven
by seven
mile peninsula with like 15 to 20
different disparate like
like
unique neighborhoods cultures yeah
cultures having their own thing between
like like the mission then like toward
like to the african-american sort of
neighborhoods down south to like the
sort of old irish and russian stuff out
to the west like the crazy downtown
stuff like the rich people up in the top
of the town and then like it's just
there's so much happening here and then
when i moved to the east bay and like
learning oh no it's actually part of
this like even more interesting like
crazy goddamn stoners up in berkeley to
like the sort of massive amount of
gentrification that's now happening in
oakland to like west oakland getting
crunched down it's like fruit failed
becoming sort of even like getting
encroached on in terms of gentrification
as well like it just seems right like
perfect for a really like interesting
story about sort of modern american um
so that i'm interested in in terms of
the environment i'm interested in as
well i was super like i have ragged on
ubisoft about watch dogs non-stop for
about two years like there are multiple
episodes at a point i feel like every
time it always comes up it's like
it's like
it's like when your brother does
something that like disappoints you and
you know like he can do better
and it's like you know ubisoft can do
better
they did great work with assassin's
creed and they drill like franchise into
the ground like i'm not a fan of the new
games they've done great work with far
cry
and they had these new franchises i even
kind of liked the crew like the crew was
like what they tried to do they did it
it's not the most compelling game in the
world i like driving games but they
tried to do it yeah
and what was disappointing about watch
dogs was like it was just happening at
the time where ubisoft had
the the peak of their crazy there were
thousands of people making these games
they also tried to make this new game
and they fell short of what i think they
probably have a quite a high internal
watermark so
we know they have it in them assassin's
creed ii and brotherhood are two of the
best open world games ever made hands
down so
like i really hope they do it i'm super
skeptical even more than i was with
watchdogs one because we know that
you know the amount of backlash that
happened over the first watchdogs uh
with the amount of backlash that
happened over the division when we
finally saw that come out so you know
there is a very much a sort of
pessimistic cautiously pessimistic thing
that's happening around these types of
open world games um but i really do hope
that they uh
like nail it this time yeah it's either
gonna be we're gonna play watch dogs too
and not love it or not like it and we're
gonna be all right done with the
franchise or it's gonna be really great
and in 10 years it's going to be that
franchise we're sick of right yeah just
go away like i don't know we're going to
be the assassin's creed we're running
out of american cities already but yeah
hopefully i mean
i'm more
excited about this than i was
24 hours ago let's say 48 hours ago yeah
because 24 hours ago ignited already
leaked a bunch of stuff about it and i
was excited so same here yeah all right
let us know what you think folks in the
comments below uh e3 is kicking off i
mean square enix are doing some madness
at the moment as well with live streams
we're seeing some deus ex stuff probably
uh the press conferences are kicking off
on sunday we're all the truck here at
gamespot is getting sent down in a
matter of hours we've basically packed
up all our stuff so e3 is alive and
kicking by this time next week we will
basically know everything that's
happened at e3 the press conferences
will be over and gamespot is covering a
lot of it we've got two stages down
there we've got the co-op stage which is
also a bunch of our friends from like
kind of funny screw attack um and a
bunch of other sites hosting stuff on
the show floor and then upstairs we are
catering demos for some of the biggest
games at e3 basically all of the biggest
games at e3 i've already seen the
running order for our three days and
it's pretty crazy we're also going to be
streaming every single one of the press
conferences as we have done for over a
dozen years uh so make sure you check
out gamesbot's twitch hit that follow
button right now we'll also be streaming
a lot on gamespot.com we'll also be
streaming on facebook and on youtube you
cannot miss it if you swing a billiard
ball on a rope on the internet you will
hit some hot gamespot e3 action so uh
make sure you join us over the coming
week thank you so much eric tay mary
kish ty root and of course simone the
puppy for producing today's show uh
thank you so much for watching
watch dogs is a game let us know what
you think about in the comments adios
you